zdf heute live herzlich willkommen etwa
sieben wochen ist es her dass das
hochwasser teile westdeutschlands
verwüstet hat an der aa ist nichts mehr
wie es war wie sieht es jetzt vor ort
aus wie gehen die menschen mit der
situation um und was erwarten sie von
der politik darum geht es heute in
unserer sendung denn heute ist
bundeskanzlerin merkel vor ort um sich
ein bild von der lage zu machen
zusammen mit ministerpräsidentin malu
dreyer aus rheinland pfalz sind sie vor
ort sprechen mit den menschen schauen
sich an wie läuft es mit den
aufräumarbeiten
zum beispiel im ortsteil altenburg in
alten adel sehr getroffen wurde von der
katastrophe und danach soll es ein
gemeinsames statement geben wir sehen
wenn wir kurz reinschauen können
da sehen wir es dass schon alles
vorbereitet ist für das statement von
bundeskanzlerin merkel und
ministerpräsidentin dreier in grafschaft
ringen aber noch ist es nicht soweit
deshalb nutzen wir die zeit und schauen
uns gemeinsam mit anna du da an wie der
rundgang heute morgen ausgesehen hat und
was die bürgerinnen und bürger angela
merkel zu sagen hatten
da sehen wir die beiden angela merkel
und malu dreyer bei ihrem rundgang durch
altenburg der ortsteil von altena der
besonders schwer getroffen wurde
man sieht die aufräumarbeiten sind noch
weiter im gange aber die große frage ist
jetzt natürlich wie kommen die menschen
an die hilfsgelder
wie geht es jetzt weiter welche häuser
müssen abgerissen werden welche können
wieder aufgebaut werden und an welcher
stelle können sie überhaupt aufgebaut
werden viele fragen die es also zu
klären gilt und jetzt bin ich mir nicht
ganz sicher ob wir zu unserer reporterin
schalten können oder ob wir jetzt genau
wir blicken jetzt auf die bilder von
anna duda die heute morgen dabei war als
angela merkel unterwegs war im
katastrophengebiet
die straße an weiter in altenburg wie
jeden tag sagt der flut es heinz ulrich
heute wieder hierher gekommen doch
wohnen kann er in seinem haus nicht mehr
das haus hat jetzt totalschaden wurde es
von der versicherung so eingestellt und
jetzt macht man natürlich die kommen
nicht so richtig aus der füße also es
weitergeht abriss oder wiederaufbau
alles unklar an tür war das badezimmer
das ist knapp ein halbes jahr alt aber
neu gemacht
du schon so dass
also um eine schau der flutkatastrophe
war altenburg eine kleine idyllische
gemeinde 600 einwohner das wasser
überschwemmte den ort fast sechs meter
hoch stand es hier in den straßen nur
zwölf von mehr als 133 gebäuden sind
nicht betroffen viele menschen werden
dem ort wohl den rücken kehren fürchtet
der bürgermeister
jetzt sind es wirklich diese struktur
geschichten dass man wissen will darf
ich hier bleiben darf ich wieder
aufbauen bevor ich investiere und eben
diese finanziellen zusagen weil da sind
schon finanzielle ängste hinter wie bei
markus thelen sein haus und sein
steinmetzbetrieb sind stark betroffen er
hat angst vor der zukunft die mehr als
ungewiss sei hauptsache es halt im
moment der betrieb der mir sorgen macht
wir müssen sehen da hängt die existenz
dran
und veraltet ist das eine zeitfrage dass
das irgendwann wieder aufgebaut werden
könnte ist klar aber es muss eigentlich
schnell gehen die menschen brauchen
jetzt zügig finanzielle hilfen und
hoffen auf die politik bundeskanzlerin
merkel und ministerpräsidentin dreier
besuchen heute erneut das ahrtal es sei
gut dass die politik hin schaut aber die
menschen hier hoffen dass auch eine neue
regierung die zusagen einhält
das ist ja gesagt dass man sie so
unterstützt jeder sagt das aber müsse
malbuch und was ankommt hier ob die noch
irgendwie die den weg ihn finden jetzt
auch gerade nicht dass das jetzt wenn
die warum ist und so was unter auf
einmal doch was war denn da die
kommenden wochen werden zeigen wie es in
berlin und für das aatal weitergeht
tja und jetzt halten wir zu julia
wischnewski aus herrlingen die auch
betroffen war und ist von der
katastrophe frau wie schnell es schön
dass sie bei uns in der sendung sind
während wir auf die bundeskanzlerin
warten wir blicken noch mal ganz kurz an
den ort wo das presse statement gegeben
werden soll und sehen dass dort sich
noch nichts tut deshalb nutzen wir die
gelegenheit um von ihnen unter anderem
zu erfahren frau die ski was erwarten
sie denn oder was erhoffen sie sich von
diesem besuch von angela
ich denke ganz konkret auf wir uns alle
oder ich auch klare aussagen und einen
plan wie es jetzt weitergeht also ich
als klimaaktivisten natürlich auch genau
dort besonders genau hin wie es jetzt
weitergehen im aufbau nutzen wir die
chance nutzen die chance für neue
energien nutzen wir die chance dieser
krise nachhaltig aufzubauen oder eben
nicht und das sind sachen wo ich
persönlich ins besonders in höheren
werde aber natürlich auch ganz andere
sachen ob es jetzt einen konkreten plan
geht und konkrete aussagen
das womit sie und ihre familie betroffen
waren wie haben sie das erlebt was
passiert ist und was ist mit dem haus in
dem sie wohnen können sie dann noch
wohnen können sie mal ein bisschen
beschreiben was ihnen passiert ist
ja genau also meine familie und ich wir
waren in der nacht des hochwassers auch
zu hause das heißt wir hatten das glück
und konnten noch fliehen aus unserem
haus haben uns an den händen gepackt und
sind durch die hintertür aus tischen
garten da steht das wasser gerade fünf
hoch und bei uns ist gott sei dank nur
das erste das stockwerk betroffen das
heißt ihr könnt es auch wieder aufbauen
aber wohnen kann man da momentan
trotzdem nicht weil heizung küche war et
cetera ist halt eben alles betroffen wie
sind sie denn gewarnt worden oder wie
haben sie erfahren wie gefährlich die
situation ist
gewarnt worden sind wir tatsächlich gar
nicht also wir haben weil das wasser
gesehen und dann also es war am anfang
es ähnlich wie 2016 und dann fing es an
immer stärker und stärker zu steigen und
dann wurden auch allen klar okay es ist
ernster als gedacht aber auch dann hatte
noch niemand die information die häuser
zu verlassen also wir standen auf dem
balkon und haben unter gerufen zu
anderen mitbürger innen ob wir jetzt das
haus verlassen sollen oder nicht weil
wirklich niemand informiert wurde was
haben sie gedacht in dem moment was
haben sie mitgenommen
also ist war natürlich
man hat ziemlich viel angst ich
persönlich hatte tatsächlich auch in dem
moment den gedanken wie soll es denn
weitergehen wenn es also was soll dann
mit meiner zukunft sein wenn die politik
weiter so verfährt wie momentan also
wenn dieses thema klimaschutz nicht
ernst genommen wird die leute dann
weitergehen aber in dem moment als sie
das haus verlassen durften kann ich mir
vorstellen haben sie eher dran gedacht
also also das haus verlassen mussten
haben sie eher dran gedacht nämlich mein
fotoalbum mit meine zeugnisse mein
kuscheltier mein handy keine ahnung was
wie haben sie diesen moment erlebt ganz
persönlich ja das war tatsächlich so als
ich stand wirklich unten im flur kurz
bevor wir gegangen sind also nicht nur
und natur und habe geweint und mein
vater gefragt wie soll es weitergehen
und dann war's okay wir gehen jetzt aus
und dann sind wir raus gegangen also das
war tatsächlich genau in dem moment dass
diese gedanken bangkok waren okay wir
haben gleich die gelegenheit miteinander
weiter zu sprechen sie bleiben noch bei
uns in der sendung ich habe ein bisschen
die pk von frau merkel im blick und wir
schauen da noch mal hin wir hören uns
gleich weiter frau wie schnell ski und
wir sprechen auch gleich mit unserer
reporterin marion geiger vor ort noch
mal aber wir sehen jetzt gerade dass die
kanzlerin hier die
ist eine bühne die bühne betritt malu
dreyer ebenfalls und das ist ihr zweiter
besuch in diesem katastrophengebiet mit
der juli war sie schon mal da wenige
tage nachdem das unglück passiert ist
damals hat sie das so formuliert eine
sehr reale gespenstische situation und
die deutsche sprache kenne kaum ein wort
für die angerichteten verwüstungen und
jetzt hören wir was sie heute zu sagen
hat und ob sie die erwartungen der
bürgerinnen und bürger erfüllen kann
die landesregierung die
bürgermeisterinnen und bürgermeister ich
bin heute zum zweiten mal hier im
flutgebiet ich hatte bei dem besuch
unschuld ja gesagt dass ich noch mal
kommen möchte und bedanke mich auch für
die gemeinsamkeit mit der
landesregierung
die botschaft die ich als ihnen zu sagen
möchte ist dass wir diese flut nicht
vergessen auch wenn schon ein paar tage
vergangen sind
und bin auch noch viele monate teilweise
jahre zeit gebraucht wird um diese
unfassbaren schäden wieder gut zu machen
und deshalb war das für mich heute sehr
eindrücklich was wir dort im ortsteil
altenburg gesehen haben eine so
umfassende zerstörung von häusern
die noch mal deutlich nachgebessert
bucht die in dieser nacht
gewirkt hat und
gleichzeitig
natürlich inzwischen schon sehr sehr
viel was geschafft wurde was aufgeräumt
werden konnte und die gespräche mit den
verantwortlichen vor ort mit dem
bürgermeister der ortsgemeinde und der
bürgermeisterin der verbandsgemeinde
wir haben noch einmal deutlich gemacht
welche wegstrecke schon zurückgelegt
wurde aber was auch noch vor allen liegt
und ich möchte allen die verantwortung
tragen allen die helfen ob freiwillig
oder innerhalb der organisationen wie
feuerwehr wie thw wie dem bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz
katastrophenschutz aber eben auch den
vielen freiwilligen helfern ganz
herzlich danken und den bürgerinnen und
bürgern die dort betroffen sind was man
an engagement an
zuversicht trotz allen schmerzes erlebt
an anpacken an dem willen wirklich
voranzukommen dass es sehr sehr
beeindruckend gleichzeitig aber eben
auch haben die gespräche gezeigt wie
vielfältig die probleme sind vor denen
die menschen stehen der herbst kommt der
winter kommt die frage des wohnens
stellt sich ganz massiv die frage wie
kommen die kinder in die schule
die frage kann mein haus wieder
aufgebaut werden oder nicht wann kommt
das geld wie wird das alles werden das
sind fragen die können wir nur gemeinsam
bund land kommunen einander bewältigen
und dieser besuch ist natürlich auch ein
zeichen des festen willens dass wir von
der bundesregierung her
mit den betroffenen ländern rheinland
pfalz aber auch nordrhein westfalen
zusammen arbeiten und das leisten wollen
was überhaupt wir tun können denn die
die betroffen sind haben es noch um so
vieles schwerer deshalb ist es glaube
ich gut dass wir diesen fluthilfe von in
höhe von 30 milliarden euro auf gesetzt
haben deshalb ist es wichtig dass das
nächste woche im deutschen bundestag
verabschiedet wird und in derselben
woche noch im bundesrat dann müssen die
umsetzung arbeiten kommen und wir haben
auch neben den verantwortlichen die das
land rheinland pfalz benannt hat ja in
der bundesregierung einen
staatssekretärsausschuss der in ganz
enger koordinierung staatsminister
hoppenstedt ist heute mit mir wieder mit
gekommen aus der bundesregierung in ganz
enger koordinierung versucht alle
anstehenden fragen und die sind
vielfältig von
insolvenz fragen von steuerfragen von
fragen wo wird was ausgezahlt wie können
wir die kommunen mit der
verwaltungsarbeit unterstützen wie
kommen da die richtigen leute hin und
nicht menschen die sich selbst erst
wieder einarbeiten wollen und ich darf
sagen wir sind festen willens an dieser
stelle wirklich so zusammenzuarbeiten
dass möglichst wenig reibung entsteht
und das möglichst alles schnell zu den
menschen kommt denn ich habe erlebt wie
sie und sie tag und nacht ja im grunde
rackern um ihren bürgerinnen und bürgern
schnellstmöglich wieder das leben zu
ermöglichen
und da wollen wir einfach dass unsere
getan dass das auch vernünftig
funktioniert und ich darf abschließend
sagen wir werden sie nicht vergessen das
wird auch eine neue bundesregierung
kontinuierlich übernehmen es war wichtig
dass wir jetzt in aachen den
gottesdienst hatten hier in rheinland
pfalz der festakt noch einmal war das
was da erlebt wurde von den menschen das
muss ausgesprochen werden da muss man
zuhören da muss man wirklich sich in die
menschen auch hineinversetzen
was ja schier unmöglich ist wenn man es
nur aus der ferne betrachtet wenn man
vor ort das kriegt man eine kleine
ahnung aber welche todesangst viele
ausgestanden haben die leute ganze flut
nacht zum teil auf den dächern oder
unter den dächern gesessen haben das
kann man überhaupt noch an und deshalb
haben wir die pflicht da durchzuhelfen
die wir überhaupt helfen können
vielen dank ja ich möchte mich als
allererstes ganz herzlich bedanken die
frau bundeskanzlerin diese frau merkel
dass sie uns heute noch mal die ehre
gegeben haben sie uns versprochen haben
es gehalten und ich habe es so empfunden
bei unserem rundgang das ist wirklich
auch ein trost und zuspruch für die
bevölkerung war die ja sie haben es
gesagt immer wieder vor allem angst hat
man vergisst sie und deshalb war das ein
ganz starkes signal am heutigen tag dass
wir nochmal gemeinsamen hier sein
konnten also vielen vielen herzlichen
dank dafür auch für die sehr gute
zusammenarbeit mit der bundesregierung
der große hilfsfonds ich weder holz auch
gerne immer wieder 30 milliarden aber
zuvor auch schon nicht sofort hilfen die
wir mit dem bund auf den weg gebracht
haben wie sollen ein nachhaltiges signal
an die bevölkerung seien das wirklich
ein wiederaufbau vor da ist von einer
größenordnung die es deutschland noch
niemals gesehen hat zuvor um klar zu
machen wir sind monate jahre mit dabei
um den wiederaufbau mit den menschen
hier zu stemmen und sie können sich ganz
fest darauf verlassen dass wir als
landesregierung selbstverständlich auch
immer auch immer wieder hier im tal
präsent sein werden ich selber bin er
häufig im aartal und muss trotzdem sagen
ich war auch schon in altenburg wie bei
hervor man diese verweigern
trotz aller zerstörung es ist schon auch
sehr sehr beeindruckend was sind sieben
wochen hier geschafft worden es menschen
die tag und nacht geschafft haben obwohl
sie so hart betroffen sind in ihrer
existenz viele haben auch angehörige
verloren und es ist einfach
beeindruckend zu sehen wie die
fortschritte einfach auch vorangehen
wissen das natürlich noch ganz viel zu
tun ist und wir waren noch mal kurz bei
dem seniorenheim heute viel leiterin die
immer noch so engagiert ist wie am
ersten tag die es geschafft hat dass die
senioren und seniorinnen mit ihrem team
wirklich auch gerettet worden danach die
immer noch sagt ja wir wollen dieses
heim auch wieder in den zustand bringen
dass die menschen zurück kommen die es
woanders evakuiert sind und sie auch uns
gesagt hat dass auch die älteren die
jetzt in bonn in köln wo auch immer sind
sagen wir möchten auch gerne wieder in
unsere heimat zurückkehren und ich will
es auch nochmal sagen der älteste bürger
bei 97 97 ja auch schon beim staatsakt
war der diese schreckensnacht miterleben
musste die ja für ganz ganz viele
menschen wirklich eine absolute
katastrophe war dann sieht man so ein
mann ein krieger lebt hat und der dann
in diesem hohen alter auch so ne so so
ein erlebnis noch mal haben wo es das
ist schon auch sehr sehr bitter und da
kann man nur sagen wie gut dass die
kinder da sehen dass es nicht kümmern
und dass hier auch dem älteren herren
dann trotzdem auch irgendwie so die
teilhabe gewährleisten dass die bei
solchen terminen dabei sind und
ähnliches vielleicht noch mal zu meinem
eindruck heute und wie sie als presse
altenburg dort 9 95 prozent zerstört
dieses ortes der häuser alles was da ist
schulen usw es werden die bürgermeister
sicher noch sagen genauer also wirklich
es ist so ein bisschen wie alles fängt
von vorne wieder an und deshalb ist
schon auch noch wichtig für mich zu
sagen wir sind als landesregierung hier
wir haben einen beauftragten vor ort
erklären der ist inzwischen auch überall
bekannt denke ich wir haben eine aufbau
beauftragte frau steigen dass sie ist
inzwischen auch bekannt wir haben die
minister und ministerinnen die meine
stellvertreterin alle spiegel wie oft
hier ist die wirtschaftsministerin
daniela schmid die oft her ist und
natürlich der innenminister der sehr
sehr häufig hier ist und wir werden das
auch nicht zeigen lassen in zukunft wir
werden nicht nur die arbeit
kontinuierlich fortsetzen in
zusammenarbeit mit den kommunen sowie
wollen auch immer wieder im tal anwesend
sein ansprechpartner sein damit die
menschen spüren ja die politik überlässt
nicht die kommunen und die menschen sich
selber sondern wir sind präsent und den
tun unser möglichstes dass ja wirklich
auch die probleme gelöst werden können
vielleicht noch einen kleinen eindruck
in den ersten wochen waren täglich mehr
als 5.000 einsatzkräfte hier im tal und
dazu noch die ganzen ehrenamtlichen
helfern helferinnen und es ist
beeindruckend wie die menschen noch
immer wieder berichten wie viel mut und
solidarität sie einfach spüren durch
diesen einsatz und auch ich will noch
mal sagen man kann nicht oft genug und
ausreichend genug danke sagen für diese
wahnsinns hilfe und wir wollen jetzt in
dieser phase sind wir schritt für
schritt die hilfe der blaulicht familie
und dieser strukturen in dauerhafte
strukturen vor ort überführen wir hatten
heute beispielsweise ein unternehmer
gesehen der jetzt schon das seniorenheim
wieder aufbaut und das ist eben die
aufgabe vor der wir stehen dass die
kommunen schritt für schritt einfach
diese aufgaben an die unternehmen dann
übergeben natürlich auch gerne von uns
weiterhin unterstützt das geld dafür ist
auch da und unsere aufgabe wird ist
jetzt sein dass wir weiterhin im dialog
bleiben denn es gibt große themen die
wir zu stemmen haben die wir auch nur
gemeinsam schaffen zum beispiel wie
können wir herbst und winter gestalten
mit heizungen die menschen die nicht
bleiben können wie wurden sie in dieser
zeit dann gibt es ganz viel aktivität
auch zusammen mit partnern wie den
kammern der dehoga aber
selbstverständlich auch hier ganz
konkret im vorort es wird eine
zukunftskonferenz geben die
dankenswerterweise der beigeordnete
initiiert hat wir werden sie gemeinsam
machen aber ich will auch hier nochmal
ankündigung es wird im september noch
eine zweite zukunftskonferenz geben und
ich sage es deshalb weil an dieser
zukunftskonferenz wir ganz konkret an
auskunft geben über den wiederaufbau von
über die frage was heißt das eigentlich
für uns mit dem hochwassergebiet was
heißt es für hochwasserschutz die angst
mit den brücken das sind alles themen
die wir gerne formulieren würden auch wo
kann man eigentlich gefahrlos bauen wo
muss man sich das wirklich er dreimal
überlegen können vielleicht auch
alternativ gebaut werden und wo finden
die anderen dann auch ganz konkrete
ansprechpartner für beratung und
information dass sie wissen sie können
dann in der folgezeit auf ihre
entscheidung wirklich sehr substantiiert
treffen und dann auch die anträge
stellen um das geld was für sie da ist
das geld ist da keine kein spielgeld in
dem es heißt es da um dort zu landen wo
die menschen die schäden haben und genau
das werden wir dann auch das miteinander
im tal besprechen vielen dank und die
verbands bürgermeisterin frau weigand
wird anschließen
ja so weit also die pressekonferenz in
grafschaft ringen beide die
ministerpräsidenten von rheinland pfalz
und die bundeskanzlerin haben betont wie
hoch das ausmaß der zerstörung war und
wie weit man aber auch schon gekommen
ist in der beseitigung der zerstörungen
und jetzt geht es eben darum wie es
weitergehen kann und angela merkel hat
gesagt sie zeigt anzeichen festen
willens der bundesregierung überall dort
zu unterstützen wo es nur möglich ist
wie ist dieser auftritt angekommen was
erwarten die menschen und fühlen sie
sich von der politik verstanden diese
fragen geben wir weiter an meiner
reporterin marion geiger sie ist vor ort
sie war schon damals vor ort als die
katastrophe passiert ist marion du hast
gleich von anfang an berichtet und auch
gesehen was dort vor ort geleistet wurde
und wie es den menschen geht wirst uns
auch gleich schildern wie du es jetzt
erlebt und was ich getan hat aber zuerst
gehen wir auf deinen gastein denn die
leiterin des seniorenheims über die malu
dreyer gerade gesprochen hat in der
pressekonferenz die ist genau dein gast
und ich bin sehr gespannt wie sie diesen
tag bisher erlebt hat mario
genauer bei mir ist die frau michaela
sebastian
das ist die leiterin des seniorenheimes
hier und sie hat es geschafft mit ihrem
team von elf leuten 85 bewohnerinnen und
bewohner dieses seniorenheimes in dieser
schrecklichen flut nacht zu retten sie
haben die menschen zuerst vom
erdgeschoss in den ersten stock gebracht
dann vom ersten stock in den zweiten
stock gebracht und dann haben sie da
über einen tag lang ausgeharrt bevor
alle mit hubschraubern und anderen
räumfahrzeugen später dann hier aus der
überfluteten ortschaft altenburg
gebracht werden konnten hallo frau
sebastian sie haben ja heute jetzt
gelegenheit gehabt mit der kanzlerin zu
sprechen wie haben sie denn frau merkel
so erlebt ich fand es also sehr unreal
genau das wie das was wir alle hier auch
mit dem hochwasser erlebt es war es
total unreal die bundeskanzlerin hier in
unserem kleinen ort zu sehen und ja
jetzt hoffen wir auf das was kommt darf
ich sie fragen was sie mit ihr
besprochen haben über was gesprochen
haben wie sie so war ich habe selber nur
er erzählt wie die hochwasser nacht war
und als wurde im allgemeinen auch
gesprochen ja was jetzt kommt wie es
weitergeht wie schnell die hilfe kommen
feldzeichen kriegen wir gesetzt hier
somit wurde das in den ganzen
rumgesprochen wie finden sie das dann
dass die bundeskanzlerin jetzt zu ihnen
hier gekommen ist ich fand ja also uns
also komisch einfach komisch dass sie
hier zu uns kommen und wie gesagt es ist
alles unwahr wie es das ganze hier
überhaupt war
sie sind ja schon so eine art held ihnen
auch geworden dadurch dass sie es
geschafft haben diese alten menschen
alle zu retten es ist ja wirklich keiner
zu schaden kommen gemeinsam mit ihrem
team ist ihnen das geglückt wie geht es
ihnen und den menschen die sie ja da in
sicherheit gebracht haben denn heute
verteidigen sehe ich mich jetzt
persönlich nicht das ist meine aufgabe
und dass die s bahn gehe einfach ans
herz gewachsen sind meine bewohner und
natürlich war es eine sehr aufregende
nacht gewesen
den geht's ja sie haben ihre heimat
verloren sie haben ihr zuhause verloren
die haben sich auf eine einrichtung
eingelassen ist schon ein schritt und
hier das war eine gemeinschaft ist meine
familie und diese familie ist einfach
weggebrochen mit allen mitarbeitern mit
allem drum und dran und so sagen die mir
auch alle immer wieder so viele ich
möchte gerne wieder zurück
sehen sie denn für das seniorenheim
meine zukunft hier in altenburg wenn der
also ist das haus ist nur gemietet wenn
der vermieter da auch sorge trägt für
ist das eine chance wieder aber wir
wollen trotz allem vom unternehmen aus
perspektiven schaffen weil es ist doch
eine zeit da uns bedenklich stimmt zwei
zweieinhalb jahre und in der
zwischenzeit müssen wir gerade
pflegekräfte gehen weg müssen wir die
hier im aartal halten und da ist cora
maternus wirklich derjenige der auch
perspektiven einfach schafft sie sind ja
nicht nur als leiterin des seniorenheims
getroffen sondern auch privat mit ihrem
haus in altenburg wir gucken sie dann
auf die zukunft hier im ort also ich bin
ein positiv gestimmter mensch ich denke
es geht weiter und so haben wir es auch
erlebt die privaten helfer die alle hier
im dorf waren oder auch immer noch sind
die haben uns stütze gegeben wir können
also wie kann nicht genug danke sagen
was wir hier erlebt haben aus allen
bundesländern und ich glaube dass es
weitergeht wir müssen jetzt allerdings
von der politik zeichen gesetzt bekommen
wirklich dass da auch schnell was
passiert dass wir müssen wissen wann wie
was müssen wir machen damit gelder
fließen diese dieses versprochene geld
auch wirklich da ankommt wo es hingehört
vielen dank frau sebastian dass wir uns
ihre eindrücke geschildert haben
ja christina das war der eindruck von
der frau sebastian von dem besuch von
frau merkel hier ja vielen dank marion
und vielen dank frau sebastian für diese
schilderung du bist ja viel unterwegs
gewesen und das was wir gerade von frau
sebastian gehört haben das war sehr sehr
optimistisch sehr sehr zupackend
was hast du von anderen leuten gehört
geht es denen ähnlich oder ist da auch
zum teil resignation oder wie geht es
den menschen
ich würde sagen dass es sehr gemischt
also einerseits beeindruckt mich das
immer wieder wie zuversichtlich und
anpacken viele auch unmittelbar
betroffene sind dass sie sagen
hauptsache wir haben überlebt wir sind
super dankbar dafür dass wir so viele
hilfe bekommen haben von helfern und
helferinnen und wir schauen jetzt nach
vorne und es wird schon irgendwie werden
das sagen viele aber ich habe auch leute
getroffen die sehr traurig sind und
denen auch jetzt nach einigen wochen das
was passiert ist erst mal so zu
bewusstsein kommt und die nicht richtig
wissen wie es weiter geht und die sehr
leiden unter der ungewissheit das sieht
die zukunft für sich nicht vor sich
sehen dass sie nicht genau wissen wie es
hier im aartal weitergeht sie fragen
sich zum beispiel ob sie mit der familie
hier wohnen bleiben möchten weil die
kinder derzeit sehr lange schulwege
haben also diese fragen stellen sich
auch und da ist durchaus auch zweifel zu
spüren bei den leuten und ja
ungewissheit und trauer
und steht den leuten da jemand zur seite
sind die behörden da sind die ämter da
sind psychologen da sind sind helfer
noch vor ort denn die aufräumarbeiten
die sind ja jetzt langsam was man am
anpacken zumindest tun konnte die gehen
ja langsam dem ende entgegen die
bundeswehr ist jetzt auch hat sich
zurückgezogen weil es für sie erst mal
nichts zu tun gibt aber sind denn die
leute gibt gibt es das gefühl alleine zu
sein oder gibt es immer noch das gefühl
von unterstützung
also es gibt unterstützung die wird auch
aktiv angeboten von notfall seelsorgern
und seelsorgerinnen die wird auch in
anspruch genommen die großen
hilfsorganisationen bieten auch
unterstützung an
das ist das erreicht die leute
und es ist aber auch richtig so dieses
allergrößte aufräumen dass es jetzt
erstmal vorbei
das heißt es ist auch zu spüren dass das
tal sich ein bisschen lehrt also zum
beispiel altenburg das seht ihr hier
auch hinter mir
da sind viele menschen im moment gar
nicht da die wohnen hier nicht die
kommen zwar tagsüber hierher in die
häuser die noch stehen die entkernt sind
umbauarbeiten zu machen aber viele sind
nicht mehr da manche häuser sind auch
abgerissen und bis diesen menschen geht
das es glaube ich sehr sehr
unterschiedlich also das lässt sich
nicht alles über einen kamm scheren da
gibt es unzufriedenheit genauso wie
zuversicht nun steht der winter vor der
tür wie sie ist denn dieser region dafür
gerüstet
der winter macht glaube ich allen die
allergrößte sorge denn die gasleitung
ist ja zerstört hier im tal man weiß
noch nicht genau wie es gelingen kann in
die noch bewohnten wohnungen und häuser
wärme zu bekommen es wird jetzt
gearbeitet an an lösungen das zum
beispiel mit gastanks an einzelne häuser
eine heizung installiert wird das
kleinere netze
installiert werden aber das ist eine der
ganz großen fragen es wird auch darum
gehen die stromversorgung also die
stromleitung zu verstärken damit mobile
heizgeräte angeschlossen werden können
die sorge der menschen dass es für den
winter oder schon vorher im herbst wenn
es kalt wird dass es für sie dann nicht
mehr möglich sein wird hier aus zu hören
und zu bleiben die ist sehr sehr groß
maria noch eine frage eine letzte an
dich spürst du wut der anwohnerinnen und
anwohner darüber dass das nicht
verhindert werden konnte
wut und verzweiflung auf jeden fall also
diese frage taucht immer wieder auf
warum nicht rechtzeitig alarm ausgelöst
worden ist
dann fällt ein satz ganz oft dann heißt
es natürlich hätte niemand dieses
hochwasser und diese flutwelle
verhindern können aber es hätte nicht so
viele leute ums leben kommen müssen wenn
man rechtzeitig gewarnt hätte hätte man
vielleicht auch aus den häusern noch
materielle dinge
retten können und es hätten nicht
hunderte und tausende menschen diese
fürchterliche nacht in todesangst
verbringen müssen also hier in altenburg
haben wirklich hunderte menschen auf den
dächern aus gehört unter den speichern
wussten nicht ob das wasser noch weiter
steigt also das sind schreckliche
erlebnisse für viele menschen hier und
die wut und die verzweiflung darüber
die ist wirklich in jedem gespräch fast
zu führen spüren entschuldigung
vielen dank mario geiger für diese
eindrücke aus dem katastrophengebiet
vielen dank an dich und wir gehen noch
einmal zurück zu julia wischnewski mit
der wir vorhin
angefangen haben zu sprechen bevor die
pressekonferenz begonnen hat und da ist
sie wieder danke fürs warten und fürs
zuhören frau wischnewski wir sind an dem
punkt stehen geblieben an dem sie
geschildert haben wie sie ihr haus
verlassen für die die jetzt verlassen
mussten für die die eingeschaltet haben
jetzt erst können sie das noch mal
schildern die situation
genau also wir müssen ja auch sagen wir
hatten großes glück sehr großes glück
wir sind alle wohlauf wir konnten uns
noch schaffen uns aus dem haus zu retten
also wir sind dann durch die hintertür
aus und als das wasser hüfthoch im
garten stand sind wieder da raus und
genau aber um die straße gegenüber da
waren die menschen schon eingesperrt und
kam auch nicht mehr raus aus ihren
häusern wo sind sie jetzt in ihr haus
können sie erst mal nicht zurück richtig
ja also bewohnbar ist es nicht wie
gesagt werden sehr großes glück dass der
zweite stock ist unversehrt geblieben
das heißt da könnten wir noch rein aber
bewohnbar ist es halt eben momentan
nicht das heißt wir sind bei verwandten
untergekommen
und sie sind schülerinnen
in rheinland pfalz ist seit dieser woche
wieder schule können sie schildern wie
ihr alltag aussieht
ja also tatsächlich relativ normal also
abgesehen davon dass man natürlich auf
dem schulweg immer noch an zerstörter
umgebung vorbeifährt und nicht zu hause
wohnt aber ansonsten ist das eigentlich
relativ normal ist tatsächlich etwas
komisch zurück in die schule zu kommen
weil die eine hälfte der schüler in so
was schreckliches erlebt hat und die
andere relativ normale sommerferien
hatte haben sie das gefühl dass sie da
ausreichend begleitet werden das was sie
gerade geschildert haben wie sie aus dem
haus raus sind das verarbeitet man ja
nicht so leicht das ist ja keine
alltagssituation gibt es da genügend
stellen mit denen man darüber reden kann
oder machen sie das mit freunden mit der
familie wie wie gehen sie damit um
doch als ich denke auf jeden fall dass
es da genug anlaufstellen gibt es gab
unglaublich viele angebote wir hatten
auch die notfallseelsorger in bei uns im
dorf also das glaube ich das schon gut
gesorgt ich persönlich habe das
glaubensgut also ich rede auch von
freunden und familie und genau als ich
denke in der hinsicht ist schon genug
sorgen dort haben sie mit ihrer familie
schon entschieden ob sie wieder zurück
möchten sie haben gerade angesprochen
sie sind frei dies verfügte
aktivistinnen sie haben auch das große
ganze im blick da gibt es stimmen die
sagen das ahrtal sowie es besiedelt war
darf man eigentlich gar nicht mehr
besiedeln man muss dem wasser mehr raum
geben das eine ist eine große politische
frage die sie persönlich beschäftigt es
wird aber jetzt für sie auch zu einer
ganz persönlichen frage wie gehen sie
damit um
ja also auch wir haben uns tatsächlich
die frage gestellt weil es natürlich
auch ein sehr prägendes erlebnis ist
also das will man ja auf keinen fall
nochmal erleben
aber es fehlt tatsächlich auch so ein
bisschen antworten der politik also in
welchen bereichen genau sollte man sich
wieder aufbauen geht es da oder ist das
jetzt so akutes hochwassergebiet ist man
es lassen sollte das war so ein bisschen
schwammig da die aussagen und wir
persönlich habe und setzt dazu
entschlossen es wieder aufzubauen
einfach weil es weil wir ja noch relativ
glimpflich davon gekommen sind und weil
es anders nicht wirklich wir sind
ergeben hat
diese zukunftskonferenz die die politik
dafür ins leben gerufen hat glauben sie
dass das der richtige weg ist um
solche fragen miteinander zu klären oder
wünschen sie sich da mehr oder etwas
anderes von der politik
ja also wie auch eben in der
pressekonferenz angesprochen wurden das
sind unglaublich viele fragen offen und
die müssten geklärt werden und sie
müssen auch an die bürger innen weiter
getragen werden und auch wie eben
angesprochen würde wurde für den winter
jetzt einteilungen ich habe schon von
menschen mitbekommen wie jetzt wieder
anfangen und sich öl heizung einbauen
wollen das sind sachen da sage ich
natürlich persönlich auch das können wir
eigentlich nicht so machen weil wir
haben gerade gemerkt was für
auswirkungen die klimakrise hat und
deswegen hoffe ich hoffe ich wirklich
sehr dass diese zukunftskonferenz das
bringt was sie verspricht weil wenn wir
das richtig angehen dann gibt das eine
riesenchance für diese klingen auch wenn
es sehr blöd klingt jetzt in der
aktuellen situation aber das ist einfach
die aktuelle lage und deswegen hoffe ich
hoffe ich wirklich dass man das
potenzial dieser konferenz auch muss
sagt julia wischnewski aus löningen
vielen dank dass sie bei uns in der
sendung waren und bevor wir weitermachen
möchte ich gerne noch einen kommentar
weitergeben für sie und alle anderen die
betroffenen waren lara marie l schreibt
über youtube ich drücke den deutschen
dieses gebietes die daumen und mit hilfe
anderer bürger und sicher der regierung
wünsche ich dass viele zerstörte orte
wieder renoviert sein werden liebe grüße
aus marokko also vielen dank an dieser
stelle für diesen sehr
aufbauenden kommentar von so weit weg
und bevor wir darüber sprechen wie das
denn mit den hilfsgeldern in der
realität so funktioniert und ob es
funktioniert und wie gut wo was ankommt
und wie schnell es geht schauen wir uns
mit hilfe von christian volk an welche
summen denn überhaupt auf dem tisch
liegen
wie sollen die gelder des bundes für den
wiederaufbau nach der flutkatastrophe
verteilt werden darauf hat sich die
bundesregierung am vergangenen mittwoch
geeinigt insgesamt stehen 30 milliarden
euro bereit die zerstörte infrastruktur
soll mit zwei milliarden euro wieder
aufgebaut werden also straßen brücken
oder schienen zum beispiel auch
betroffene privatpersonen und
unternehmen will die regierung helfen
sie können sich demnach bis zu 80
prozent der entstandenen schäden
erstatten lassen in härtefällen kann
auch der gesamte schaden übernommen
werden diese hilfen soll der bundestag
am dienstag offiziell beschließen drei
tage später muss noch der bundesrat
zustimmen ab oktober können die gelder
aus dem hilfsfonds dann wohl beantragt
werden
tja und jetzt sprechen wir mit einem der
sehr gut beurteilen kann welche wege
diese gelder nehmen und wie schnell oder
wir langsam das geht zugeschaltet ist
uns jürgen opitz der bürgermeister von
heidenau in sachsen und ich hoffe dass
wir ihnen gleich sehen und auch gleich
hören und darüber sprechen können wie
das bei ihm damals angekommen ist 2013
hat die elbe einen riesigen schaden
angerichtet opitz bei ihnen mit dem
hochwasser mehr als 26 millionen euro
wie lief das damals bei ihnen
ja wie fast bei uns wir hatten zwei
hochwasser und wir hatten ein
vergleichbares hochwasser 2002 mit
wesentlich mehr zerstörungen und mit
einer wesentlich mit einem wesentlich
größer und überraschungseffekt also wir
waren wenig da auch vorbereitet und das
hochwasser 2013 das war kam von der elbe
und das kann sehr langsam wir hatten
alle selbst die zeit um uns darauf
einzustellen die notwendigen
vorkehrungen zu treffen dinge nach oben
zu räumen
vor davon daher möchte ich eigentlich
lieber über die erfahrung aus dem
hochwasser
2002 sprechen weil erstens waren die
zerstörungen größer zweitens war wie
gesagt der schock stand der bevölkerung
wesentlich ausgeprägter vielleicht
vergleichbar mit
einigen orten in rheinland pfalz und
nordrhein westfalen
wie schnell ging das mit der auszahlung
der hilfsgelder wie schnell wurde den
menschen tatsächlich geholfen
also im jahr 2002
ist der damalige ministerpräsident
professor milchmarkt in dem
katastrophengebiet aufgetaucht mit
seinen legendären gelben stiefeln und
hat den bürgermeistern
zugesichert dass mindestens 90 prozent
aller schäden
bezahlt werden
und es gab dort keine
einschränkungen
gemeint war sicherlich erstmal die
öffentliche infrastruktur
und die hilfsbereitschaft seiner zeit
war riesengroß als ganz deutschland aus
europa haben sehr viele spenden die
diesen aufbaus fonds gespeist haben und
es waren ja nicht nur die landesmittel
die bundesmittel sondern es waren eben
auch sehr viele private spenden erst
dann
nach gewissen gesichtspunkten zu
verteilen darf aber am anfang war die
zusage so edel ich mich dass jetzt auch
mitbekommen habe dass 19 prozent wir
waren jetzt von 80% geräte aller schäden
mitfinanziert werden und das war für uns
damals
eine sehr große ermutigung die dinge
auch anders zugehen
weil das hier in dem chat sehr viele
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer beschäftigt
man muss ja trennen zwischen staatlicher
hilfe die im kabinett beschlossen wurde
die nächste woche vom bundestag und
bundesrat auf den weg gebracht werden
soll und auf unglaublich viele
hilfsgelder von privatleuten die
gespendet haben an verschiedene
organisationen wie kommt man denn als
betroffener an diese verschiedenen
töpfen können sie das mal ein bisschen
erklären
also diese spenden sind alle zusammen
geschlossen wurden nach fast in der
sogenannten phoenix daten wahr und
verteilten diese spenden auch zum großen
teil individuell durch die
hilfsorganisationen die sich
zusammengetan haben also caritas und
diakonie um nur zwei zu nennen
die sind tatsächlich von haus zu haus
von baustelle zu baustelle gegangen und
haben mit den menschen gesprochen was
sie welchen geldbetrag sie momentan
benötigen um die notwendigen arbeiten
für die absehbare zeit tatsächlich
vornehmen zu können und das war sehr
unterschiedlich
viele die in ihren häusern bleiben
konnten die haben eben das thema heizung
damit geregelt andere deren den
viele andere dinge kaputt gegangen sind
konnten sich wieder neu einrichten und
denjenigen die eben ihr haus nicht
bewohnbar vorgefunden haben den konnten
daneben teilweise unter fünfte in
pension mitfinanziert werden und diese
hilfe war sehr individuell und die so
sehr schnell abgeschlossen wurde zentral
registriert so dass man im nachgang
immer noch nachvollziehen konnte wer hat
denn wann wie viel bekommen so dass
diese frage der gerechtigkeit sind
angemessenheit dann auch in gewissen
abständen überprüft worden ist aber ich
kann sagen das geld ist sehr schnell
dort angekommen wo es benötigt es gibt
natürlich immer wenn es um viel geld
geht auch viele fragezeichen und auch
viel sorge darum dass das geld auch da
ankommt wo es hin soll
jürgen matt zum beispiel schreibt über
facebook ist sind doch schon millionen
private gelder gespendet worden wo ist
die kohle wer hält sie zurück wer hat
die kontrolle über die gelder kassieren
die verwalter die hilfsgeld der
hilfsgelder geld für ihre tätigkeit und
wie viel denn also das ist schon ein
bisschen sehr zugespitzt aber wenn ich
sie richtig verstehe herr opitz dann war
das in ihrem fall so dass über diese
gelder buch geführt wurde und auch im
nachhinein
nachvollziehbar es wer wie viel geld
bekommen hat also die sorge dass dieses
geld irgendwo versickert ist die
begründet oder ist die unbegründet ich
meine in deutschland ist diese frage
unbegründet
man muss allerdings auch beachten
für bei uns war es so dass vielen
menschen diese aussage dass 90 der
schäden getragen werden und dass die
gelder auch dort ankommen wo sie
benötigt werden das hat viele sehr
ermutigt und ich warne davor den leuten
einfach jetzt schon riesen große
geldbeträge in die hand zu geben wenn
sie die gar nicht benötigen also es geht
ja nicht darum das sparschwein wieder
aufzufüllen sondern es geht darum die
arbeiten die notwendig sind damit die
menschen wieder in ihren häusern in
ihren wohnungen leben können dass diese
gelder aufgebracht werden die gelder die
jetzt gerade von jedem benötigt werden
diese chance die muss da sein und wenn
die
hilfsorganisationen diese spenden in
minister weise thesaurieren um eben
einen längeren prozess und ich kann nur
sagen das ist ein längerer prozess um
den zu begleiten dann versichern diese
gelder nicht sondern wie werden
tatsächlich angespart um dann wenn mehr
hilfe notwendig ist also wenn die
wohnung trocken ist zum beispiel wenn
die trockner die auch bezahlt beschafft
werden müssen wenn die wieder abgezogen
sind dann ist das geld
notwendig um sich wieder einzurichten
vorher brauche ich das geld für die
einrichtung nicht bar in meiner hand das
und diese überlegung die muss man etwas
natürlich kommunizieren
das ist ganz klar das haben wir vor ort
versucht den leuten immer wieder
klarzumachen ich hoffe jeder
bürgermeister jede bürgermeisterin in
den betroffenen gebieten des gut beraten
unterwegs zu sein mit den menschen zu
sprechen sich in die reihe der
notfallseelsorger der
hilfsorganisation zu stellen um sicher
zu stellen dass tatsächlich die not
gesehen wird und dass die nord und zwar
die dringendsten ort tatsächlich auch
bewältigt werden können nun gibt es ja
auch fälle wo vom haus nicht mehr übrig
geblieben ist als die bodenplatte also
wo alles so zerstört oder weggeschwemmt
wurde dass man völlig von vorne anfangen
muss jetzt gibt es leute die haben der
elementarschadenversicherung und welche
die haben sie nicht aus dem was sie
erlebt haben
wer ist im vorteil bei wem geht es
schneller wer
wem geht es besser in diesem fall denn
davon auszugehen ist ja dass beide wenn
es möglich ist und die rahmenbedingungen
stimmen ihr haus an der stelle wieder
aufbauen können wenn das nach prüfung
aller möglichkeiten möglich ist aber
sind eben zwei unterschiedliche fälle
von geldern die aus verschiedenen töpfen
fließen
wir haben das damals so regeln können
dass tatsächlich erst mal alle das
notwendige geld bekommen haben um wieder
wohnen zu können auch um ihre häuser
wenn es sind sinnvoll war darüber möchte
ich dann später auch etwas sagen um ihre
häuser wieder aufzubauen und abgerechnet
worden ist nach einer gewissen zeit ich
will jetzt nicht sagen zum schluss weil
das ist einfach zu lange sondern es wird
nach einer gewissen zeit abgerechnet und
da wird genau geschaut wer hat dann im
nachgang geld von seiner versicherung
bekommen und dann sind dort auch gelder
die aus spenden zum beispiel oder aus
öffentlichen kassen gezahlt worden sind
wie sind dann auch wieder
zurückerstattet worden aber die
versicherung sind im regelfall nicht so
schnell wie die spenden verteiler vor
ort auch das muss man feststellen und es
macht keinen sinn die leute ewig hin zu
halten und zu sagen na ja vielleicht
einem halben jahr habt ihr ja die chance
von ihrer versicherung das zu bekommen
was ich glaube so viel solidarität muss
man dann schon aufbringen und sagen also
auch wenn es hier über öffentliche
gelder oder über spendengelder eine
vorfinanzierung gibt dann wird das
hinterher abgerechnet die frage der
gerechtigkeit stellt sich natürlich
immer aber in notzeiten muss man einfach
sagen muss auf diese frage der
gerechtigkeit nach hinten gestellt
werden weil es geht darum dass man allen
hilft
in der zeit in der aktuellen zeit hilfe
braucht
bevor wir hier weitermachen möchte ich
auf eine sache eingehen die hier im chat
sehr sehr viele menschen umtreibt
nämlich die frage ob in dem schlamm vor
ort schadstoffe und giftstoffe sind ob
es im moment gefährlich ist vor ort
sekunde hobbits wir sind gleich wieder
beim eigentlichen thema ich würde nur
gerne das tatsächlich beantworten denn
das kann man beantworten
denn gerade heute hat die zuständige
ministerin umweltministerin an der
spiegel in rheinland-pfalz gesagt dass
jetzt die behörden mit der untersuchung
der böden auf mögliche schadstoffe
begonnen haben zitat unser augenmerk
liegt dabei vor allem auf sensiblen
bereichen wie kinderspielplätzen rund
120 flächen dem aartal und der westeifel
sollen untersucht werden und die proben
werden auf unterschiedliche schadstoffe
wie zum beispiel heizöl untersucht erste
ergebnisse sollen in den kommenden
wochen vorliegen soweit also an dieser
stelle und ich hoffe dass die frage
damit für den chat soweit man sie jetzt
beantworten kann beantwortet ist herr
opitz es geht ja nicht nur um geld es
geht ja insgesamt darum
ganze dörfer wieder auf die beine zu
bringen wieder eine zukunftsperspektive
zu geben
wie haben sie das damals geschafft
also wichtig war dass
im stadtrat dem gemeinderat
dass über diese dinge gesprochen wird
wichtig ist dass die initiative
möglichst vor ort
möglich ist dh je weiter unten in der
verwaltung für archiv entscheidungen
getroffen werden können umso schneller
werden diese entscheidung sein und im
regelfall um
sachgerecht während dieser entscheidung
sein ich war damals sehr froh dass er da
meine nächsten ob man sie denn milbradt
tatsächlich den bürgermeistern an der
stelle sehr sehr viel zugetraut hat und
das auch seinerzeit die kommunalpolitik
den bürgermeistern sehr viel zugetraut
hat es wurde eine schadensersatz gemacht
und da waren insbesondere natürlich
erstmal die kommunalen gebäude und die
kommunale infrastruktur
erfasst
und dann ist eine prioritätenliste
erstellt worden der finanzbedarf ist
festgestellt worden und dann hat man
halt mit der priorität
angefangen wenn es denn wirklich war
also dass leistungen zu gegensatz zu
schaffen die ölheizung das thema ist
vorhin angesprochen wurden nach 2002 gab
es in heidenau meine ich keine heizung
mehr
diese dinge die müssen sehr strategisch
angegangen werden und wie gesagt mein
petitum ist tatsächlich den
bürgermeistern vor ort und den
gemeinderäten vor ort diese kompetenz
einzuräumen damit das was am
notwendigsten ist und im wahrsten sinne
des wortes wenn der winter vor der tür
steht bei uns war hob hochwasser seit
dem august
da muss tatsächlich an den nächsten
winter gemacht werden an die notwendige
technische infrastruktur und natürlich
die ist die voraussetzung dafür dass die
mieten warte das private wohnumfeld
wieder hergerichtet werden kann
sagt der bürgermeister von heidenau in
sachsen jürgen opitz vielen dank dass
sie bei uns in der sendung hat waren und
berichtet haben wie es damals bei ihnen
funktioniert hat danke schön herr opitz
und
damit bedanke ich mich auch bei ihnen
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer ohne
allerdings nicht den hinweis zu
vergessen auf unsere
spendenmöglichkeit es sind schon mehr
als 86 millionen euro zusammengekommen
wir haben gerade gehört wie gewissenhaft
mit diesen spenden geldern umgegangen
wird deshalb wenn sie spenden möchten
das hat das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
erreichen sie über das spendenkonto der
commerzbank bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104
106 100 stichwort zdf hochwasser
damit also vielen dank an sie fürs
zuschauen und tschüss und bis zum
nächsten mal